yeah I'm nervous but I took you to IHOP
and asked you to be my girlfriend and
we're not even chatting hi my name is
Dasha and I am here to talk about my
first relationship hey I'm Zack and
today I'm gonna be talking about my
first relationship so my first
relationship was in college I'm 19 my
first relationship was in I want to say
8th grade
well relationships what's going on
but I think it counts and I will make my
case what made it a relationship was
that you know I remember us like sitting
down and like having a conversation
about it and being like you know do you
want to be my girlfriend and like I was
like yeah let's do it
I think now I define a relationship as
you know you know two people sitting
down together and like making their
intentions known I think in eighth grade
it was like hey do you want to be my
girlfriend and that's what I defined it
as it was with someone who will call
Michael Michaels like okay so Michael
was a friend of one of my college best
friends and so he'd always been in the
picture but I never really saw him like
that until my junior year in college not
gonna use a real name not bad it matters
like you also feel like you know why not
let's go with Sarah yeah she was just
like super nice and one of like I think
she just like one of the nicest girls in
my class and I thought she was cute we
would like talk a lot like during break
and stuff there was a party as always
like I think it was in a corner and I
was like with my friend and I was like
oh my goodness like do I try and like do
something and she was somebody who was
like oh we gonna make this happen I
don't even know how she's been able dit
but at a certain point we were just like
dancing with each other and we were like
the only two people in the room I was
like there's not even music
I was in little awkward kid not even
that just like nervous and
I started like chatting with her a lot
on a I am Instant Messenger you know
like when you're in like class everyone
knows each other and you're like who do
you like I think the question was
brought up in AI am Instant Messenger
and I was like time to shoot my shot I
said yeah and then she did as well and
that was that history I believe our
first date was at the LA County Fair oh
yeah that's good I was taking a
psychology of relationships class at the
time they were talking about how like
high adrenaline dates are really good
because then it allows you guys to like
bond and so he's like oh but you have to
go on that ride that like shoots you up
and then like drops you and I was like
absolutely not but then I was like all
right only because we're on this date
will I do this and I think part of me
did it only because I was really curious
about what I was learning and coming I
like I think back to that date in that
memory and it was really fun we got
fried Oreos first day went through an
IHOP I have three eighth grade eighth
grade yeah yeah yeah and then like it
was super super awkward and then we went
to a movie it was literally just kind of
like you know what you're like this and
you're just kind of like I'm nervous
that's what it was but the reason that I
call this a relationship is because
after the movie I said do you want to be
my girlfriend and she said yes and I was
like wow this is it was happening so
here's the thing he was cute and he was
nice and he did treat me well but when I
like think back to the relationship like
I don't know how well-suited we actually
were from one another that was a time
and in my in my life where I was very
insecure and like I wanted a
relationship so badly between him and I
for like my first boyfriend I appreciate
it it feels weird saying that only
because the next thing gonna say is that
his parents were racist so when they
found out that I was black man you know
what it was not a good relationship and
it's because you know it was very junior
high it was very much like hell hands a
little but then like didn't talk much
you know I guess that point we were like
okay like come on
your boys yeah I'm nervous but I took
you to IHOP and asked you to be my
girlfriend and we're not even chatting
but you can't expect much at that age I
feel like but I think I did I feel like
at that time I like wanted it to be like
a girlfriend boyfriend you know we're
gonna be highschool sweethearts but it
wasn't it wasn't serious so it ended he
decided to graduate from school early
but then didn't recognize that the
internship that he had was going to stop
because he was no longer in school and
so he then got super stressed out and
depressed about not having a job and I
was studying abroad in Italy at the time
and then in the mists of dealing with
that that's when his parents found out
because they didn't know who I was or
anything and so then his mom basically
gave him an ultimatum and it was like
either you choose her us he chose me but
like obviously he was pretty much like
an only child so like that created a
really big wedge that I don't think that
he knew how to handle and it's a lot
your braces parents asking you to choose
between your girlfriend or them so I'm
in Italy and he calls me and he's just
like yeah like I just think that I'm not
in a good place and you know now in
retrospect I would no you were not
that's place to be in but at the time
like it was like it was a lot it ended
how it began hey I am Instant Messenger
who initiated she initiated I know after
I hop and everything so you know log on
to AI AM we start chatting and then she
says that she thinks we should just be
friends and I say that's yeah fine
that's totally fine
I like wasn't really devastated and then
everything was back to normal because we
don't really talk about it anyway
I feel like I've learned to like put
myself out there a little more certainly
was both of us being like I'm not gonna
talk to you it kind of made me realize
okay maybe when I'm gonna have more of a
actual serious relationship it should be
like serious and also even just like the
stigma of like asking someone to be your
girlfriend just learning that at like an
age of like oh I should just like do
that when I know
were actually like we've actually like
each other you know your first
relationship you you've learned a lot
boyfriend and girlfriend
it's a label but you should like earn it
I learned that I didn't really need a
relationship to define myself and that
sometimes there are certain things that
you just gotta say no to like racist
parents
[Music]